well today local and state health  officials expressed concern  with the recent rise of the uk coveted  variant in nevada  and the impacts it can have the director  of the nevada's covet 19 mitigation and  management task force  added that the current vaccines show  positive signs against this variant but  it's another reason why the state is  slowly reopening  we also asked about pfizer's latest  report stating its vaccine is a powerful  protective  indus in adolescence as they  are able to publish the data goes  through the fda process  the advisory committee on immunization  practices and so um  we'll lean on that on that those  recommendations  and what that data shows as we move  through that particular  age population on monday april 5th  vaccinations will be open to all  nevadans ages 16  and older you are still encouraged to  book an appointment